wir haben ja da gehen wir gerne mal raus
und greifen das gerne auf markus kaim
sicherheitspolitik experte der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik herr kaim ich
meine das ist ja klar eine einseitige in
diesem fall die ukrainische sicht der
beiden klitschkos hier aber diese frage
stellt sich ja schon wie
gesund einerseits ist wladimir putin bzw
wo geht das denn noch hin und wie
gefährlich kann dieser krieg noch für
europa für deutschland für den rest der
welt aus ihrer sicht werden
punkte dazu dass wir bis nichts über die
befindlichkeit des russischen
präsidenten und ich halte auch nichts
davon darüber zu spekulieren ob er so
wie gerade angedeutet verrückt
irrational unzurechnungsfähig ist oder
anderes mehr wir haben ihn zu nehmen wie
er ist mit seiner entscheidung und
seinen aktionen und uns damit
auseinanderzusetzen
das zweite zu einer frage der nuklearen
eskalation nach all dem was wir wissen
ist es eben nicht so auch in russland
nicht dass nur eine person darüber
entscheidet würden einsatz von
nuklearwaffen
das ist ja auch bei allen beteiligten
klar mächten in den usa gleichermaßen
nicht der fall und vor allem vor dem
hintergrund dass man eine situation
immer befürchtet hat dass ein präsident
oder eine entscheidungsträger wirklich
verrückt werden könnte irrational
handelt krank wird und dann alleine
entscheidet die welt mit den abgrund zu
ziehen das ist sozusagen das alptraum
szenario gewesen und auch der
amerikanische präsident kann nicht
einfach unkontrolliert man entscheiden
wir verkürzen das immer mit dem bild des
roten knopf ist aber die wirklichkeit
sieht etwas anders aus auch in russland
scheint ist ganz wo sich die formuliert
kontrollen michaelis und zu geben und
größere beteiligung von der einzelnen
generellen
so dass wir hier glaube ich in szenario
haben was nicht zum treffen ist und ein
dritter punkt bei all dem was wir wissen
greifen die mechanismen der nuklearen
abschreckung nach wie vor
präsident putin hätte mit einer
nuklearen reaktionen der usa zu rechnen
in geringerem umfang gegebenenfalls
frankreichs gegeben dass großbritanniens
und damit ist das neue gleichgewicht des
schreckens wiederhergestellt werden wir
das den punkt machen will dass wir zum
ersten mal nuklearer waffen in der hand
eines diktators haben dann drängt sich
der fan nordkorea auch wo wir das auch
haben und auch nordkorea akzeptierte
regeln der nuklearen abschreckung von
daher leuchtet mir das argument bei
allen vorständen das für die ukrainische
situation ich glaube nicht dass heißt
haben geklärt also sie gehen nicht davon
aus dass in irgendeiner form einen
nuklearkrieg droht drohten eine weitere
eskalation dieses krieges und wie könnte
die aus ihrer sicht aussehen
das würde ich ganz anders machen worden
zumindest vorsichtig vor um jede wissen
ist nicht aber die option besteht weil
wir stellen ja fest dass der russische
präsident das eigene politische
schicksal hat sich mit diesem
militärischen fans super knüpfte hat
auch wenn er anders heißt aber er hat
grosses politisches kapital investiert
hat sich vor die russen russische
sicherheit gestellt und sich als
befreier der ukraine präsentiert der
befreier von den nazis in der ukraine
und kann so zu sagen ich zurück einen
igel niederlage ist inakzeptabel ist
nicht eingepreist das zweite die
kriegsziele russlands so unklar sie sind
im moment ich finde es aus dem
militärischen ein bisschen die
politischen ziele ableiten sie bleiben
unklar sind zu wenig um in um die
russische führung zufrieden zu stellen
also ich gehe nicht davon aus und danach
sieht es ja im moment auch nicht aus
dass die militärische operation enden
würde in den nächsten tagen mit der
bereitschaft das reichte zu akzeptieren
zu einem kompromiss zu kommen und ein
drittes argument netz die ich müssen wir
uns immer noch ein ofen gibt es ein
großes militärisches ungleichgewicht in
nackten zahlen wenn wieder mal dran uns
erinnern an die zahl der raketenwerfer
der artilleriegeschütze der bekannten
fahrzeuge der panzer und anderes mehr
dann bleibt russland weit überlegen und
wir stellen fest dass russland um die
kosten als magentis konflikt ist noch
nie zu hoch zu treiben diese noch nicht
zum einsatz gebracht präsident putin
könnte das aber wenn man all das gesamte
zum gesamtbild fügt dann würde ich sagen
sind wir weit davon entfernt von einer
russischen deeskalation
wir sprechen gleich weiter markus kaim
und bleiben gerne bei wladimir
wladimirowitsch putin der sich heute mit
seinem russischen amtskollegen
lukaschenko getroffen hat ist ja einer
der wenigen noch verbündeten des
russischen präsidenten das ganze hat den
sotschi statt gefunden und wir haben
ganz aktuell beide und das zumindest in
teilen was sie dort gesagt haben vor
liegen
herr kaim sie haben am ende ihrer
letzten der ausführung was gesagt da bin
ich dann nicht darauf eingegangen weil
ich erst mal herrn putin lauschen wollte
aber sie haben gesagt die deeskalation
bleibt also eher unwahrscheinlich und
auch wenn man den beiden ebenen zugehört
hat lukaschenko und putin dann klingt
das so gut was anderes wird man auch
nicht erwarten aber was heißt das denn
für uns jetzt die nächsten wochen monate
möglicherweise jahre fragezeichen
also ich glaube über kurz oder lang muss
die bundesregierung jetzt erst mal ihre
eigenen ziele definieren die sind ja aus
nachvollziehbaren grund so ein bisschen
unscharf geblieben der bundeskanzler hat
gesagt die ukraine darf nicht von hier
an ostern darf nicht gewinnen und so
langsam nähert sich der punkt wo wir uns
glaube ich diese und nicht länger
leisten können gegenüber russland wie
gegen morgen der ukraine muss die
bundesregierung deutlich machen dass sie
zu unterstützen bereit ist und was sie
nicht zu unterstützen bereiten die
versuche heute beispiel der ukrainische
aussenminister hat in netstal mehrfach
zu protokoll gegeben das ziel der
ukraine seien auch die krim
zurückzuerobern was sich deckt mit der
völkerrechtlichen position der
bundesregierung dass die eu pläne nicht
zu russland gehört gleichzeitig können
wir die augen meter hohe verschließen
dass russland sie annektiert hat und
dass eine weitere installation wäre und
das ist so ein beispiel wo die
bundesregierung erstens präzisieren
müsste was sie will zweitens mit der
ukraine sich in ein einvernehmen setzen
müsste
konsens und wo diese
ja ihren dritten punkt ja noch
und drittens der schnell gemacht sie
sich dafür einsetzen müsste für eine
internationale verhandlungslösung das
ist tausendmal gesagt es wird nicht
dümmer zu wiederholen weil letztlich
auch wenn uns das nicht gefallen mag
dadurch dass präsident putin in konflikt
begonnen hat nötigt die westliche
politiker ihn auch um ihn zu wählen kann
verstehe ich sie richtig dass sie
tatsächlich für eine anerkennung der
realitäten sind das heißt für eine
anerkennung in diesem falle auch des
bruchs des völkerrechts der anerkennung
der krim weil einfach ganz klar ist dass
russland diese grimm nie mehr hergeben
wird oder ist das am ende nicht am ende
diplomatie hinter den kulissen von denen
sie vielleicht noch wir als
öffentlichkeit erst mal nicht erfahren
werden weil natürlich sich ein
bundeskanzler nicht hinstellen kann
sagen kann ja gut dann ist die creme
eben jetzt aufgegeben wenn dafür der
krieg endet
ich wollte gar keine position vertreten
und vor allem ihr das letzte was ich
will ist der bundesregierung will die
haltungsnoten zu geben ich kann durchaus
verstehen dass sie nicht öffentlich
darüber spricht mein punkt ist nur zu
sagen es bleibt eine unschärfe in der
deutschen politik und mit fortschreiten
kriegsverlauf ändern sich eben auch
bewegung und ziele der beteiligten
akteure und so lange man so sagen so wie
man im februar noch eine gewisse
unbestimmtheit in der deutschen politik
akzeptieren konnte angesichts der
unerwarteten situation ja ist das so
langsam immer schwieriger auszuhalten
kann da muss ich noch mal nachfragen
aber ich möchte sie und sie auch meine
damen und herren nur schon mal darauf
vorbereiten dass wir für 14 uhr die
pressekonferenz der grünen
bundestagsfraktion beziehungsweise der
grünen partei erwarten da sehen sie
schon das leere podium sobald es losgeht
bei ricarda lang der parteivorsitzenden
sind wir natürlich live dort aber er
kann doch noch mal die rückfrage jetzt
ganz explizit bitte ruhig und eine kurze
antwort also wäre das denn die richtige
position der bundesregierung ob sie
jetzt mit uns kommuniziert oder nicht
aber zu sagen also am ende lieber
kriegsende und die krim in
anführungszeichen aufgeben auch
international
davor aus nicht nach der trojaner
kompromisse geht also nach gegenwärtiger
unter passt der ausdruck der
gefechtslage sie ich nicht dass die
ukraine
exterritoriale größe weiter bestand
haben würde wie sie vorher ausgesehen
haben würde dann wird vielleicht zu
überlangen szenarien kommen zu
übergängen mit volksabstimmungen don was
aber nach aktuellem stand heute wir
sprechen uns in sechs wochen wieder
breit macht sie das ändern wurde das
territorial kompromisse machen
während zu machen sein und ich finde es
durchaus sinnvoll und plausibel dass die
bundesregierung verweist zugleich finde
ich da würde ich sie auch unterstützen
hat die bundesregierung einen wichtigen
punkt den sie immer wieder betont es
sind nicht mehr die bundesrepublik und
die westlichen nationen in der nato und
der eu darüber zu entscheiden haben was
die ukraine als kompromiss als
akzeptabel erachtet das ist das privileg
der ukraine selber nur gleichzeitig
finde ich durchaus angemessen dass die
bundesregierung oder die bundesrepublik
als führungsmacht europas ihre prämissen
ihre interessen durch die lösung liegt
doch dann kam relativ einfach
entschuldigen sie diese vereinfachung
vielleicht einfach auf dem tisch also
der dom bass und gewisse östliche
gebiete plus die krim gehen an russland
dafür endet dieser krieg die frage ist
nur wie kommt man dahin oder sehe ich
das falsch
nein ich glaube sie sehen das völlig
richtig die elemente einer regelung ich
weiß nicht was sie sein kann wie
dauerhaft die sein kann ihr liegen drück
dich auf dem tisch die sind ja in den in
den trainings russischen verhandlungen
auch bereits angesprochen worden wir
reden über eine neutralität der ukraine
wir reden über sicherheitsgarantien
wir reden über einen minderheitenstatus
der russischen minderheit in oslo karine
wir reden über autonomiestatus für den
don bass und und und und das ist alles
vielfach thematisiert worden also die
stellschrauben sind bekannt dass dem
publikum moment woanders nämlich dass
die beteiligten akteure die beiden
großen konfliktparteien im moment er
sich noch mehr versprechen und auch
versprechen können von der militärischen
auseinandersetzung sollte das nicht mehr
der fall sein sollten die größere kosten
zu befürchten haben wirtschaftlich
militärisch politisch und ihr kalkül
sich ändern dann können sie uns zu
konzessionen bereit sein im moment sehen
wir das einfach nicht und das lässt mich
so zurückhaltend seien an einen
diplomatischen durchbruch jetzt zu
glauben er kann sie sehen dass also so
dass im moment sowohl wladimir putin und
russland als auch wolodimir selensky und
die ukraine denken sie könnten
eigentlich noch mehr rausholen als das
was wir hier eben gerade auf den tisch
gelegt haben also das militärische
vorgehen das kann der schluss zu
letztlich müssen wir sehen dass eine der
beiden parteien die andere niederringt
dann könnten wir uns sehr schnell eine
regelung
begegnen bestimmbaren konfliktparteien
da sehen wir aber nicht danach sieht es
im moment auch nicht aus im moment ist
er ein aneinander
ermüdender sich vorbei ist und der
ausdruck der stellungskrieg ist ist ja
fifa und zurecht gemacht worden war das
der fall ist sich moment zumindest jetzt
nicht die chance für eine politische
lösung aber noch einmal das mag sich in
wenigen wochen ändern wenn der grad der
ermüdung des aneinander müde geworden
sein wenn ich das so sagen darf ein
anderer
kurzes letzte rückfrage zu diesem punkt
dann müsste die ukraine im zweifel eben
auch die bitte und den antrag auf
aufnahme in die europäische union aber
auch zurückziehen wenn ich das
wahrnehmen was wir vor zwei antworten
gesagt haben nämlich die unabhängigkeit
im regen in der tat sie hat ja zumindest
angedeutet dass sie die nato mit kraft
völlig zu den akten legen würde die
frage einer eu mitgliedschaft stößt er
innerhalb der eu gerade hier auch in
berlin auch sehr große vorbehalte das
wäre sicher teil der verhandlungsmasse
und die entscheidende frage wird sein
wer den politischen rahmen für mögliche
verhandlungen bietet und der
nachfolgende un generalsekretär vor
wenigen wochen in kiel von dem moskau
war ist ja ein bisschen belacht und man
damit deren händen nach hause gekommen
ist ich glaube dass ein bisschen früh
wir werden vielleicht auch ein
renaissance ein wiedereintritt der
vereinten nationen in diese
verhandlungen sehen wenn es darum geht
institutionalisierte rahmen für solche
verhandlungen und von dingen für die
überwachung ihrer durchsetzung sowie